i remember when i was younger i was uh
the moment i realized i was like
this peasant life isn't for me i i was
like 10 years old
10 years old i don't know arbitrary age
of young age
we went on a plane somewhere and i was
like wow already privileged you get to
go on a plane that's not [ __ ]
oh come on it's like [ __ ] ryan ryan
yeah
it's hardly a [ __ ] brilliant ever
been on easyjet joey
i don't know from privilege you're doing
like a it was like a layover or
something and then so this was like uh
it was like a it was a flight that was
going to like australia but it stopped
in like where we were going to
in amsterdam so it was like a two-hour
flight but i remember we were sitting in
an economy and i was like mum
why do they get to go in the really
really cool looking one they get to lie
down they were like oh because that's
really expensive and i was like
why don't you pay for it like i was like
we can't afford it and i'm like
we can't afford it just just get a good
bank account you guys have a job right
like yeah we kind of thought it's too
expensive i'm like oh well
if you were my kid i would have slapped
you over the head no i was just asking i
was like how much is it i don't know how
much it is you know how does it work
right
i'm young as [ __ ] i don't know how much
it costs i have no notion of this before
right
i'm like i'm like how much is it
how much why can't you afford it yeah
i'm like what so you're saying you're
telling me that those people over there
have enough money for it
nah that's not right that's not that's
not if they can get it i can get it [ __ ]
that
that was like a mindset that's how i've
always been in life i'm like if someone
else can have it i can have it why can't
i have it
why not why not
did you think like that as a kid i don't
know i'm i was
like in my head i always thought if
someone else could do it i can do it
when i was like 10
all i thought was like thank you father
for buying me a packet no no i was
grateful but i was always wondering
you never wondered why those other
people who had like i wanted
but i was like well the fact that we're
not there right now means that
they're different right they're the same
as us they just got lucky
[ __ ] that i'm like but they want you to
believe they want you to believe they
are like 10 000 iq we we earned this
[ __ ] off no they didn't they got [ __ ]
lucky [ __ ] off no you didn't
you made a few good decisions and that
you made an air conditioning company
good for you
how to get privileged just get lucky
there's a lot of luck involved
90 of the people in that first class
[ __ ] born into wealth bro it's
[ __ ] that is true
not fast the same rich people giving
each other their kids money
i'm like [ __ ] that i deserve that why
did i deserve that
what's wrong with having that mindset of
being like if they can do it why can't i
get it i mean
there's nothing wrong with having that
it's just funny that you were having
that mindset like
literally yeah like for me you're just
you're just trying to be a pro gamer
from a young age i always was like
i just want to like why why why cause
why not why aren't my parents mid-maxing
life right now
i just always thought if someone else
could do something always from young age
if they could do it i could do it
that's great that's a great mentality to
have when it's talking about
you know like privilege because money's
like a
taboo subject right you can't say that
you want to get a lot of it not like
i i mean i usually just think that like
[ __ ] like everyone wants to have a
lot of money yeah of course that's
it i mean but no one wants to admit that
right people don't want to admit that
they're like that
i mean people were always like if i had
that but they're never like i'm gonna go
for it because it's embarrassing
admitting to your friends being like i'm
gonna be a millionaire i'm gonna do go
for that [ __ ] right because that sounds
you're like oh yeah all right all right
yeah all right all right go back to
walmart yeah
you know what i mean it's like dude [ __ ]
that let people try if they want it man
let it [ __ ] up like absolutely if you go
bankrupt do before 30 so you can at
least like fix your [ __ ] you know
like what was it i saw a thing that was
like most people uh have the most
impactful years in your life are like 40
years old
you like the people who do the most the
important things are the ceos of the
company all that stuff
it's when you're 40. so just [ __ ] up try
and do a bunch of [ __ ] yeah
exactly honestly go for gold when you're
like 20. why the [ __ ] no take some risks
while you're young
yeah honestly like i what i try to tell
people is like especially those in their
mid-20s because i feel like
everyone hits like their mid-20s or like
23-24 where they realize
oh i'm just going to be working for the
rest of my life
you know and you know everyone gets
their first job you get excited getting
your first job you're like damn
i'm actually getting paid for once i'm
not i'm not a peasant anymore
because let's be honest being a student
is that's what they want that's what the
system wants you to think exactly
being a student is just like man you've
just gotten used to living like a
peasant right
so yes this is normal yeah you're just
like i i remember
like i remember like somewhere in my
mid-20s when i just realized man
how the [ __ ] did i just live off cup
ramen for a good like five years of my
life yeah that's not
normal yeah and i've just like entered i
like internalize that to be like dude
dude night out versus cup ramen
night out anytime of course of course
gotta get your priorities right but then
you realize
well i have a i have a job with a
disposable income i can i can
have like a decent living and that's
what you would hope
that most people would have if they went
through university if they went
if they got an education um it's a lot
harder now
yeah absolutely like it's it's i've you
know i was
lucky enough to get even my first job
after i
graduated from uni which a lot of people
have a hard time
have a hard time doing now but i will
say if you are able to be in a position
where you can give yourself a safety net
then by all means [ __ ] up in your 20s
[ __ ] because
your 20s are the best point where you
can [ __ ] up in that in life
and still it'd not be the end of the
world yeah you still have enough time to
recoup right and like
you know get back to ground zero yeah
that's why i was just like [ __ ] it yeah
i'll try youtubing it's probably a
terrible idea to lose two or three years
of my possible long
engineering career today because [ __ ] it
like i i'm gonna try it like why
wouldn't i try it like it'd be something
not to try you know yeah go for gold but
i mean i
i mean it does get to a point where um
because i i mean if i went down like the
engineering path i'm sure you too you
know
eventually in your 40s you'd probably
have a very cushy wage you'd you know
you'd be very
very nice you know you've got to afford
very fine things in life when you get
you can be a chartered engineer the pay
you get is very good yeah
and when you work in certain places
where the engineering gets you know more
difficult or whatever like you can start
getting nutty money yeah yeah
um but i was just like yeah [ __ ] that
i'd rather take 20k a year doing
something that i like that also has the
chance
to make way more down the line you know
and that's what i was always like though
i i always thought why
settle you know i would rather risk
losing at all
trying to make a million dollars and
then just settle for like
you know to me it's like
you know i i can do that at any point in
my life i i can settle down and and do
things
you know because you never know like
without career right like it could start
happening tomorrow for all we know yeah
like if you
can become the biggest [ __ ] youtuber
on the planet next week dude you're set
for life you know what i mean so it's
like
but i i don't even think of it like that
it's not like how i
see youtube anyway but i just i just
would rather risk and do something
that's
kind of like oh that's kind of could
lose it all he xd
could like just become homeless tomorrow
fine
better start camping
but like i mean it's i'd rather try it
like yeah of course
i mean i think it's important to like
recognize that some people
are just not in the position to be able
to drive that's true yeah because yeah
because like i was very very lucky that
i i i built up the savings and
i also had a really good family that set
me up exactly exactly because like i i
will say this right now like my i was
never brought up like my family weren't
in the best of financial positions
at all but like i was lucky enough to
have like a mom and dad who like
work their [ __ ] asses off to like get
me through and give me
a better opportunity than they ever had
and that's why like right now
i'm trying to like most of like most of
everything i earn i like
i like spend on them i spend more on
them than i do and me because i feel
like
it's my way of like paying back the
opportunity that they gave me yeah
because good boy yeah i mean it's
it's such a good song i mean dude like
yeah i mean my parents like
especially my dad he came up from like
[ __ ] poverty almost in [ __ ]
thailand and
luck somehow found found his way to
england and worked his [ __ ] ass off
had a much harder life than i ever went
through so of course i'm like [ __ ]
dead isn't that [ __ ] badass though
like
you know he had a dream move to england
and then his son's like engineering
degree and then now he talks about how
many titties
that part of the story is
[Music]
yeah exactly because i i feel like it's
you know it's it's a fallacy where you
you know you think money solves every
problem that you have where money money
does not solve
it it makes life significantly easier
yeah it sounds so pretty
privileged when you say that but like no
not like as someone who you know has
been poor in her life money doesn't
solve every problem but
there is a point in your life where
money is ninety percent of your problems
right and just and and once is your
problem you don't really have time to
think about anything
other than money exactly and like my
mentality when i was a kid
was just i just want to get by and have
and be
like comfortable you know because i'm
saying and you know i i feel like that
was that was my big driving force to
like really
try to be successful and to take risks
is just because i was just tired of just
not like knowing what my life situation
would be like five years down the line
it's just like
how am i how the [ __ ] am i going to take
care of my parents when they get old
like that that was that was a big
[ __ ] thing for me
there's definitely a time when i was
like 16 to like 18 where i thought
i really love video games i don't really
care what job i get
i just want to be able to play games
after work that's right that's what i
genuinely i thought i wanted for like
yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then when i went to university
it like very much kicked in i was like
i don't think i can do an eight-hour job
again like i think
i can't do that i did a three-month
internship to know that i don't want to
do
this for the rest of my life yeah i was
like i mean i'm more
more proud of people who love that that
line of work
i was jealous i was at the time i was so
jealous of the people that loved
my course and what we were doing because
i felt like they were just so op
with school yeah yeah they like got
through it they got all the good
opportunities because they enjoyed it
like i just didn't enjoy it i couldn't
try because i just didn't care i have
so much respect for people who you know
can go to their you know nine to five
job and be like
at the time when i didn't know what the
[ __ ] i was doing i was so jealous i was
like [ __ ] man i wish i knew what the
[ __ ] happened
right you know and i'm sure for every
person like you know i got very lucky
and i found something that i loved and
that
luckily makes money somehow as my mom
just believes that it did for a very
long time yeah
sometimes i think a lot of parents did
yeah somehow it makes money right and
you know i'm sure for every you know one
of me that got very lucky
there was probably 10 people who never
really found what they liked and just
had to like kind of just be like all
right well i gotta get a job yeah yeah i
can't i can't do nothing on my life yeah
exactly
that sucks i think one thing i've
realized more as i've grown older
is that as a kid we were sold this idea
that there's only really one
one way your career path can go right
it's like education
university get a job to do with your
degree and your career progresses from
there and that's like i had this
i had that mentality for like the
longest time of my life and now like the
older i've got the audio i've gotten
the more people i've met who have had
like the
weirdest [ __ ] career paths yeah yeah
we've had a lot of those people on the
podcast i feel like in the entertainment
industry you do meet the people who kind
of are just bouncing from things to
things just trying to figure out what
they want right
no not even enjoy life not even in
insane just like living in japan as well
like
like i like meeting like teachers who
have like found
opportunities just randomly like like
sometimes like what i'm trying to say is
that as a kid
i was i you know we got put this
pressure on that
by the time you go to university or by
the time you finish high school
you need to know what you want to do for
the rest of your life i wish they didn't
[ __ ] sell me that long
that is the biggest lie of the [ __ ]
world i
feel especially especially for like
especially when you're young adults the
biggest lie of the [ __ ] world is
thinking that
once you start a career path that you're
gonna have to stick on this
for like the majority of your life and
that's such a [ __ ] lie
and like another big lie is thinking
that you need to go to [ __ ]
university or college
to have to have a decent career that's
also a [ __ ] lie there are so many
different career paths um that are
available to you
that is not just higher education
because as an asian i was taught that if
i don't do higher education i'm a
[ __ ] failure
i don't get that a i failed doesn't it
no i'm not i'm not
like i'm not even talking about being a
youtuber because obviously
we we are very lucky to be able to be
youtube absolutely
you know but like i'm not even talking
about like oh we're youtubers that's a
different different career path i've
found no i've met like so many other
people who have like
just found random jobs i mean [ __ ]
maelyn found
her [ __ ] job through craigslist like
it is about just trying and looking and
just yeah at the right place at the
right time and making sure you take
every opportunity that comes your way
exactly
i just said yes to everything yeah yeah
and that's why i miss every opportunity
you don't take yeah man yeah
you know and if you which is in the uk
which is something that i just did
really didn't enjoy it was like the
culture of you go to work you go to the
pub and that's it like you never try and
do any self-improvement you never try
and like
look for any other opportunities like
looking for another job is like oh wow
what's wrong with you yeah
and like there are so many opportunities
out there for different jobs that you
like never even thought about
until you uh until it's just on your lap
like
have you ever have we ever talked about
kenny before like your friend
no i'm talking about kenny what he's
doing oh yeah kenny's my friend who's uh
lives in niigata
yeah he's just he's just crazy guy he's
great i love him he's amazing he's so
funny he's really
he's he's a proper out he is and uh he's
just he's up in niigata in the middle of
japan
and he's half japanese half welsh and
he's just a fake priest and like i think
i've spoken
before that my friend's a fake priest
yeah yeah but like he teaches english
and then he's also a fake priest and
that's just what he likes doing but he
also just
doesn't really care about being in one
place for too long he's like i'll just
kind of go wherever and this is the one
he literally just goes places and he's
like all right what's going on let's
figure out let's try and get a job here
yeah yeah yeah he just doesn't give a
[ __ ] because
i i have a friend who's similar to that
because like i i i couldn't do that
like like but he's badass he just turns
up and does what he wants
it's great like and he you know he's
always super happy and super optimistic
and i'm like
[ __ ] are you british are you really like
you grew up in the uk right how are you
this is the japanese side that's king
yeah yeah
he just turns up he's like yeah what's
going on like you know always is a good
time talks to anyone he meets like it's
just like
yeah i feel people like that are usually
like the most optimistic people in the
planet
right because i have a friend like that
who was like he's an animator for
an anime studio here he he did like that
i met him through like the pop team epic
stuff
but like he also just like goes out he's
just like i'm just gonna go on a road
trip for a month
and just like try and make some money
along the way and just see what happens
yeah and like he he comes back with all
these like insane like stories of just
like
him on the road being like yeah i just
like walked into this like random cafe
got a job for like two days and then got
some money and used that for like fuel
to just like go to the next place i'm
like
that's so [ __ ] cool because yeah i
can never [ __ ] do that
no i could not bring myself to just be
like i don't know where i'm going to be
tomorrow yeah
i could not i couldn't do that i
couldn't do that either i need like some
some like at least a little bit of a
plan i need some kind of direction
yeah yeah i like playing yeah i like
playing i i like i just like spreadsheet
all my like spending in university like
a penny and i would like have like a
prediction of like my spending coming up
and
what i was allowed to spend yeah yeah
literally everything in a spreadsheet
and then when i started like my youtube
started giving me some money and in
university i was like oh my god this is
amazing i was like i don't need to
spread [ __ ] anymore
[ __ ] this why am i why am i like [ __ ]
why am i like spending hours a week
updating this [ __ ] spreadsheet
it doesn't [ __ ] matter anyways i'm
not gonna spend that much yeah [ __ ]
matter
oh my god yeah yeah and like like to go
off what we were saying i don't
i'm not saying like there's no place for
like higher education
university or everything but i'm still
glad i went yeah i mean i'm so glad i
went but what i'm saying is
like you don't feel the pressure to need
to go just because you don't know what
you want to do with your life you know
that's that that's that's the big thing
right because
it's it's so it's such [ __ ] that by
the time you hit 18 it's just the
expectation where it's just like
you need to know what you're doing now
you know you you are not you are you
you your birthday is ticked over you are
now an adult yeah
like you you need to know everything
there are 30 year olds out there 40 year
olds who don't know what the [ __ ] they
want to do yeah because
like mcdonald's was like 40 years old
yeah right yeah it's like
i don't really feel too bad about it
you're like you just you know like i
said earlier like you'll do the most
the most productive years of your life
like 40 years old so as far as i'm
concerned you're just [ __ ] up until
you get to the point where you can like
actually do [ __ ] yeah yeah exactly
because just you're just [ __ ] up
enough until you've found out a way to
not [ __ ] up right build the foundation
of the character you want to be you know
yeah
it all goes back to the snowboarding
right like just tumble a couple of times
until you learn how to not don't work
yeah
what a good landing cue credits get good
get good in life